Oh
[Applause]
shut up much look the very first thing I
think that when I look at you as I see
this hair and it's fantastic how would
you describe your hair with my head yeah
I just feel like this is my style this
is my how it looks like so I don't want
to change the look but if you had to
describe your hair in one word what's
the word sexy there was a video that
went around of you playing basketball
this basketball workout okay
another interesting to foreigners in
basketball but not very interesting the
basketball and it's talking watching
more and no more much more players so
who are some maybe my basketball players
now that you're more into I like to run
tips on them
okay LeBron to us stiffen clear yeah
somebody shot distance yes in the [ __ ]
of course Michael Jordan nice that's a
good list yeah so expectations for you
are pretty high like last year you had
40-plus goals so now it's like anything
less than that is beautiful um right
it's like the expectation for the pic
from the people is very very high so so
basically you score forty sunset last
season now they want you to score 60
next year I wanted you to score 90 and
it's just doesn't work like that but if
I scored thirty goal and my team like
served in the table or thoughts are you
going to be happy no some people label
you as a diver what would you say to
that I don't know I have nothing to say
we have a
and I'm sure when we get the penalty
they will also say that what is wrong
yes but of course you disagree that you
are at ice yeah I have even nothing to
say about it okay I think that a lot of
fans would say that the Premier League
is more important than the Champions
League go to December that I think for
the for the city for the club they
prefer the Premier League more I prefer
both to be honest but he has to decide
between one I had to sacrifice the
Champions League for the Premier League
because I love the pre-medical not
violence jealously but yeah I can
surprise for the city and the club
the pain is too great to bury what a
pain
what are your memories of the injury
that you suffered in the Champions
League final no when I think about this
it was very very bad you know final
Champions League big dream for yourself
and for the city for the fans for
everyone what win the Champions League
and that time was mentally like it was
very very bad especially when I get
substitution I went to dressing room was
just crying because I feel like
Champions League is over and the World
Cup is over so it was it was very tough
for me at that moment how long did it
take you to crawl out of that sad moment
I think it's it still held on till now I
mean because you didn't win it so you
feel like you were close to win the
Champions League final or Champions
League and you didn't win it I won't
play the World Cup it's it's a dream but
I'm not yet I go to my room I was like
almost crying every day before the first
game I didn't play I was I went I was in
the past and I was like I was crying the
past I went to the bathroom I was crying
the bathroom because I won't start a
game I want to play but in the meantime
I know that I'm not fit at all to play
but in that in one moment like it
disappeared this is all so difficult
yes so difficult have you had the chance
to speak to Sergio Ramos since and how
do you speak to him and for me the
subject is Klaus I'm not talking about
him now I'm just talking about that the
injured and how it's hurt and that's it
so now that the injuries behind you you
know how badly do you want to win it now
honestly special requests fair skin in
next game so against Barcelona so
something very very huge to play against
Barcelona semi-finals
Wow so we have
team now in the semi-final from lost
seasons so that's something very big
also for us as a player as a team so
that show how much we are improving
Messi now you're gonna meet him on the
field and the semi-final what's that
gonna be like yeah that's great most of
the people calling the best player ever
in the semi-final that's something very
huge and something like very very
excited for me and for the team also so
that's something great